hola hola cómo están
bueno pues hoy hemos estado hablando de
cómo era la reinvención y si vieron
hemos empezado a tener un poco el tema
de cómo teníamos que estar como líderes
que fueron a las primeras pláticas y
luego hablamos de la creatividad como
teníamos que ser esas personas creativas
que se comen los escenarios que están
haciendo un cambio en vidas y así como
en la inversión que hoy está hablamos de
la parte de chisme hoy quiero a todos
convencerlos que realmente podamos
vivirlo pero en un aspecto bien
importante la innovación y porque le
puse en meta innovación
mucho de la palabra y viene de la parte
hasta griega decimos que es como innovar
de la innovación como estamos viviendo
esta innovación todos los días y se ha
contado una historia muy personal de
cómo he cambiado un poco el aspecto de
entender de ser una persona que empezó
como desarrollador porque soy ingeniero
en software cómo empezó como
desarrollador y como siempre me decían
gustavo tienes que ser líder de proyecto
y esas apps que padre llega su momento
en tu vida donde tienes que tomar la
decisión si programando y queriendo
inventar cosas o tienes que irte hacer
es el líder de proyecto y gerentes
también me voy como líder de proyecto
pero claro que siempre cuando te van
diciendo eso tú te vas dando cuenta que
hay un paso más y un paso más porque
luego a elier te decían bueno pues que
tenés que el gerente y bueno es que
luego tienes que ser director y así te
vas poco a poquito a tratar de
reinventar todos los días
luego puse a pensar oye y esto cuando se
acaba porque si no estamos viviendo el
día al día en el trabajo lo que nosotros
queremos hacer y siempre tenemos que
estar reinventando nos por lo que dice
él al lado pues cuando va a acabar esto
y eso me hizo reflexionar mucho que ese
es el punto que quiero aparte que el de
hoy la parte de reflexión de cómo nos
reinventamos como personas y cómo la
innovación puede ser una parte
fundamental en nuestras vidas y antes
que empiece a entrar muy bien en el
contexto porque si no lo mantenemos las
personas de innovación lo primero que te
explican cuando hay que innovar hay que
empezar innovar es hablemos un mismo
lenguaje
significa eso que todos que estemos aquí
entendamos el mismo concepto entonces y
me voy a la parte de que es innovar si
quiere bajar un poquito nada más en el
manual de oslo te dice innovar y no voy
a meterme al orondo sino lo que triste
es innovar es el poder hacer un cambio
hace un cambio en algo que estamos
haciendo hacer algo nuevo pero siempre
presentarlo
alguien más no existe una innovación que
te la crees tú solo la innovación
siempre pero siempre tiene que ver a
alguien que la escuche alguien que la
vive alrededor tuyo entonces qué sucede
con esto que al momento que
empezamos a hablar de innovación y
empezamos en este mundo en el que
estamos viviendo de del emprendimiento y
lo que realmente es este el que existen
escuelas porque ahorita ya se está
fundaron escuelas de emprendimiento y
que hoy nos digan que no somos nadie si
no emprendemos déjenme decir los que
estamos muy equivocados
méxico no necesita más emprendedores
para matar pero méxico no necesita más
emprendedores méxico necesita
innovadores a poco creen ustedes que los
modos que ahorita con el space sex y
demás el es emprendedor él es una
persona de negocios y les pueblo en mí
cosas maravillas de él y cuando os
podemos dar todo su pasado y demás y por
las maravillas de él pero ustedes creen
que él va a llegar al espacio por el
mismo
él está llegando al espacio porque tiene
cientos de innovadores en sus filas
tiene gente que está trabajando con él y
que realmente cree en su visión pero que
ellos mismos están creyendo en su propia
visión de cómo hacer las cosas como
innovar día tras día para poder lograr
esa visión que él tiene junto con mi
visión de apoyo entonces que ya no le
vuelvan a decir que el punto de tu vida
para poder ser el gran de aspecto de
empresario o emprendedor es tengo que
generar una startup ya dejemos ese mito
de silicon valley del startup nation
dejemos un poco el mito de que para
poder realizarlos como personas tenemos
que ser emprendedores yo les digo
tenemos que ser innovadores tenemos que
empezar
poder vivir sabiendo que podemos generar
nuevo conocimiento
ahorita con la pandemia que sucede había
mucha gente que sí así como inventaron
una vacuna tan rápido se habíamos pasado
10 15 años investigando y no hemos
podido encontrar la cura del cáncer
alguien de aquí tener respuesta de por
qué hicimos una vacuna te rápida porque
se juntaron cientos de miles de
innovadores de investigadores de gente
que realmente podía hacer un cambio en
este punto que estamos viviendo gente
que no estaba sentada esperando a ver
como su emprendimiento generaba este
unicornio era gente que realmente tenía
que hacer algo en este momento
entonces con esto en vista el vivir la
parte de innovación es el poder actuar
rápido el poder hacer estos cambios pero
no les hablo también de un cambio tan
radical con la palabra disrupción que
muy muy muy muy poca gente lo puede
lograr innovación abarca un campo enorme
podemos innovar en nuestras vidas
podemos innovar en nuestro trabajo si
hoy en día llegó mi trabajo me siento en
una silla y me abro un excel y me pongo
a hacer macros y se preguntó se fue toda
mi vida voy a hacer esto sí porque es
que mi jefe me está diciendo no
ustedes pueden innovar en sus trabajos
pueden hacer las cosas diferentes y eso
es lo que quiero practicar se el día de
hoy como estar innovando todos los días
desde tu trabajo de tu casa con tus
hijos con tu familia
empecemos a realmente vivir algo nuevo
en el que no sea monótona nuestra vida
quiero que la pandemia no se nos enseñó
mucho que el estar encerrados en un
cuarto de dos por dos no lo es todo y
veo que mucha gente me decía en la
empresa hoy es que está bruto el home
office vámonos todos de home office
ya pasó un año y no sé cuántos años va a
pasar más y me dice bueno este fosis
está gustado pero en una salidita no
pues vamos a comer aunque sea oye pues
vamos un poquito a la oficina hoy
empecemos a despejarnos pues sí porque
el haber quedamos encerrados entendimos
que el estar sentados haciendo algo
monótonamente
pues eso ahora sí te hace pensar de tu
vida que va a suceder porque la vida se
te acaba en un segundo conozco muchas
personas
que vivía en su vida tan tranquilamente
y relajadamente porque sin yo tengo todo
arreglado y se enfermaron no sabe cuándo
va a partir de este planeta y qué mejor
que realmente dejar un legado dejar algo
estacional hoy te hablamos en la primera
conferencia de la parte que actividad de
mexico como nos poníamos en nombre de
alto a mexico
hoy les digo como nos ponemos en nombre
de alto nosotros mismos
y bueno y para todo esto
realmente hay muchos factores que
podemos estar hablando de innovación
si quieres bajar un poquito
el primero que quiero hablarles es sean
por favor curiosos o sea que realmente
empiecen ustedes a que descubra las
cosas diferentes yo sé que con el
trabajo otra vez puedo llegar mucho a la
monotonía y demás pero realmente el que
ustedes empiezan a conocer nuevos
conceptos no se están esté viendo la
parte de el nuevo mundo que está creando
que son los metaversos no si por ahí
alguien de ustedes ha conocido eso como
es la realidad virtual y empezar a
conocerse mucho por la parte de los
metaversos que es un universo con radio
virtual donde van a convivir personas de
todas partes del mundo en una sola parte
en una pantalla te puedes poner tus
lentes de dale virtual aumentada y vas a
empezar a platicar con otra gente
hablamos de los nfts hablamos de la
internet de las cosas podamos hablar de
demasiadas cosas lo primero que decirles
es seamos curiosos científica empecemos
a salirnos un poquito de nuestro
estándar de vida de pues estoy checando
mi email estoy en él estoy en el
facebook si no empecemos a ver cosas muy
desconocidas para poder empezar las
entender si gustan bajar la presentación
por favor
entonces lo primero que realmente
podamos ver la parte de ser curiosos lo
segundo es empezar a especializarnos si
un innovador lo que hace es empiezo con
la curiosidad empezó a entender
realmente qué es lo que tengo que hacer
pero luego tengo que empezar a ver cómo
poder
especializarme en estos temas y les
hablo desde temas de tecnología de temas
de
productos servicios de lo que ustedes
quieran hasta de cocina ustedes puede
innovar en todas partes y empiecen a
especializarse a documentarse sí sí es
hora de empezar a leer empezar a
entender dónde estamos ahorita parados y
hacia dónde queremos llegar
luego
atrévanse por favor hacer las cosas ya
les dije seamos curiosos veamos que
hiciste en la internet sobre eso
empecemos a documentar empecemos a vivir
lo que está haciendo lo que está pasando
pero también atrevámonos yo sé que es
muy difícil llegar a un trabajo y
decirle a tu jefe
de esta manera lo estoy haciendo ahora
quiero hacerlo de esta otra para ver
ejemplos que te van a decir que no y ese
trabajo créanme no es para ustedes
váyanse a un trabajo en donde realmente
si ustedes quieren hacer esta parte
innovación y quieren aventarse que los
dejen aventarse si un día vamos a cosas
bien un día no un día vamos a aprender
pero realmente si no nos atrevemos a
hacer las cosas vamos a quedar sin la
dimensión que es el tema del día de hoy
vamos a dar siempre estar viviendo lo
mismo y lo mismo una y otra vez no se
atrevan se generen esas nuevas hipótesis
que realmente digan hoy quiero llegar a
tal lugar y cómo puedo llegar
y claro para qué hacemos eso en la
cultura de decir que nunca se debe
fracasar es lo peor en innovación lo
primero que te explican es tienes que
fracasar n veces ahí me tocó estar hace
muchísimos años cuando empezó el boom de
silicon valley este y me acuerdo un
inversionista y me decía cuando viene
una persona aquí en frente mío lo
primero que quiero saber es cuántas
veces ha fracasado ellos le decían este
cuántas rayas tiene el tigre y dice oye
porque es una persona que nunca ha
fracasado nunca se ha arriesgado a hacer
las cosas siempre he vivido en la parte
de conformidad eso es lo que hoy quiero
decirles es aprendamos a fracasar pero
aprendamos a poder aprender de este
fracaso
y bueno y al final por favor apasionen
sé
algo que sí quiero decirles es ya
después de vivir toda esta parte de
innovación de poder entender hacia dónde
queremos llegar necesitamos apasionarnos
de lo que realmente existe en el mundo
entonces si no hacemos nosotros nuestro
propio cambio
si no estamos
idealizando nos que podemos hacer
generar nuevas hipótesis documentando
nos aprendiendo además nos vamos a
quedar aquí sentados toda la vida y hoy
pasa una pandemia y mañana no sé qué va
a pasar más pero sé que no la va a
arreglar alguien que no seamos nosotros
si nos seguimos sentados sin
reinventarnos y nada más estar no seguir
viendo el internet y demás y ver series
lo que ustedes quieran y no aprender de
eso nos vamos a quedar sentados en donde
siempre hemos estado soy la invitación
muy muy personal es el porfavor
reinvente monos y hoy les quiero dejar
en este espacio el que podamos vivir
ahora con la conformidad de la
innovación que ustedes lo pongan día a
día en respecto de sus vidas y que lo
pasen a la demás gente que si ven una
persona sentada a los suyos que está
ahorita con con problemas psicológicos
por todo lo que está pasando de la
pandemia y les den esta palmera en la
espalda y le digan empieza a reinventar
y hoy en día hay una idea de algún
camino muy fácil que es la innovación no
necesitan tener ni masters ni doctorados
ni nada en el que les diga eso porque me
tocó en una plática que decían que nada
más la gente que tiene máster y
doctorados e innovaciones les puedo
decir no es cierto en todos los equipos
que yo he estado he tenido gente de
todos los niveles académicos y la
mayoría sabe sé de innovación lo único
que falta es el compromiso de
apasionarse y esa palabra se lo voy a
repetir cientos de veces vivan
apasionada sus vidas cambien las y
rimenses muchas gracias
[Aplausos]